foreign
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Genevieve shamard and I
look after the partnership globally
between capgemini and Google
and I'm Jennifer Marshawn I lead our
Google Cloud Coe for the Americas I kept
Gemini and I'm Steve Jones I'm the EVP
for data-driven business
thank you guys we'll hear about you a
little bit later
uh so you've heard about generative AI I
think throughout this conference so far
and I won't surprise you when I say 70
of global organizations are currently
exploring with generative AI according
to Gartner
I could go into a bunch of reason why
you should pay attention to this
technology and to to these Solutions but
this is not this type of presentation
so we're not going to cover what gen AI
is and it's not will also not share why
you should give it a try and I'm
definitely not the person to talk about
llms you guys had great demoted
yesterday around harder technology work
this session is more about how you get
your Enterprise ready to take out this
technology
how do you protect your data and your
organization there's a lot of fear
around being like one of those early
adopters that then met the the headlines
and then how did you play for the long
game
and how we can answer this question is
because capgemini we went through this
process right so we're going to use our
own experience over the last three
months on how we ramped up our
capabilities to actually like get up and
running around gen AI
so we'll share how we got started and
we'll have Jennifer share more in
details like practical applications of
gen AI will also share about how do you
set the right foundations how do you
reach scale and then where to go from
them
so basically we probably uh have been in
this position we were in this position
where do we start
uh are we just like following all of
those technology fed and it's not gonna
be for the long run so we had multiple
ways to go about it and we also had very
lofty goals so at the top you see what
were set up in terms of targets we
needed to basically get 65 thousands of
our Cap Gemini resources get excited
around gen AI we wanted to by 2024 which
a library of 500 use cases and we also
wanted to have 100 MVPs
and over the the last three months what
you see as a result is that we were able
to get about 10 000 people to actually
care about gen AI without with without
our company and can train about it we
now have a library of 250 use cases and
we also have like demonstrable assets
um and you're probably trying to figure
out like how do I reach an expert level
across the globe and at scale how do I
identify what is a good use case how do
I prioritize and so on and how do I
actually work the talk in terms of
understanding how this technology work
and go to MVPs so we ask ourselves all
our those questions and to get to those
results basically it's maybe a recipe
that you guys would want to take into
account is that we had buy-in from all
the lines of business from top down to
really mobilize the entire organization
we also use that mobilization to
prioritize where we would want to play
engine Ai and what we would not want to
play right what are the key use cases
that we want to prioritize we also
created a Coe Global of a team of
experts that can really guide us in
terms of putting those llms model
together there we did a global Summit to
go after those 65 000 people and then
end up with 10 000 just for the first
three months to get the volume of people
that can
walk the talk around Gene Ai and lastly
we did a global hackathon around those
prioritized use cases to have really to
use assets right and we're seeing some
of our of our clients using that formula
to bypass all of the typical like three
months phases every time and accelerate
all around so to talk more about the
hackathon I'll pass it on to Jennifer
thank you
all right so first I want to briefly go
over the hackathon by the numbers and
then and then we'll show some of the
output of that so to start with we had
given ourselves two weeks to go through
the hackathon it ended up stretching
into into about three weeks from the
start of the first kickoff session we
had one thousand and 121 registered
hackers representing 29 countries so a
lot of interest in our organization to
really start playing with the technology
uh we also had 16 mentors and 16 judges
from kept Gemini and Google alike and
the output of that is we had 51 live
application MVPs coming out of out of
the teams formed
um so so very exciting uh and I'll
actually
do a a brief playback of what the
hackathon process looked for like for us
um to start with I'll introduce the
three uh top three winners so at first
place we had a review aggregator so this
took diverse set of of customer reviews
and and aggregated it into one easy to
read review for Consumer saving time as
well as providing feedback to product
and marketing teams second place focused
on a human-like experience for travel
planning so an agent to help find
undiscovered travel travel locations and
personalized itineraries for those and
at third place we have a chatbot
marketing agent so taking
data from the Enterprise and presenting
it to marketing teams in a
conversational format not requiring any
technical expertise
so I'll play a quick video please
[Music]
welcome to gen III hackathon 2023 what
our product does is that it takes the
reviews for this product and summarize
this this into a short form of content
so if we decided to filter removing the
positive reviews we can see what the
negative things are about this product
so we can get a better feel of if this
is something I'd want to buy there's a
need for a solution that goes beyond
conventional tourist attractions and
Commercial recommendations one that
harnesses the power of AI to curate
personalized and itineraries and
guarantee experiential new adventures an
MVP built using vertex AI Studio not
only able to gather valuable insights
from a data set but as well to create
marketing campaigns we call it the
designer oh and there we go
join the creative revolution
foreign
so uh before we hop into the demo just a
little bit about our favorite MVP it
focuses on a store and historic concept
so so what we've done is we've taken the
digital human Avatar which which we've
all seen we think is pretty exciting I
think it it takes it to the next level
by by adding generative AI uh to to the
digital human why so with digital humans
consumers are willing to engage a little
bit longer with technology however our
Focus Group found that a digital human
can go from hot to not pretty quick if
if the content remains static
so what we've done is we've used
generators and generative fallbacks
along with structured and unstructured
data to enable a store and a store
concept so we started with the with the
store and store concept allowing
customers to maximize their Channel
reach with minimal investment we layered
the digital human with conversational AI
headless Commerce apis on the back end
for a conversational Commerce kiosk and
then the degenerative AI expanded our
our capabilities in the ordering process
to allow for open-ended questions
and allow us to more gracefully handle
exceptions so I can find what's right
for me
uh so could you imagine using a digital
person whether it's to to order order
food at a at a restaurant whether it's
to return and learn about new products
or receive product training
um at the edge in store
um you know you could use this at a
retail store hotel lobby really taking
the contact center to the edge where the
consumer is
um and and the the concept is as well
the underlying conversational bot can be
used in in additional channels without
the digital human front end so think the
same bot being used to to place the same
order from your car from your Google
home device from your mobile phone
so in this in this demo we're using the
Gen AI app builder chat info bot and the
Palm uh
large language model so let's take a
look
hello
hi welcome to capgemini's Corner Shop
store in a store
my name is Casey and I'm a digital human
I can help you place an order or browse
are you a loyalty member with us
so so first I'm going to ask her a
question to show the generative AI
through Enterprise search so so we've
loaded structured and unstructured data
about our business and you'll see that
she she prepares and scripts the
response based on that
what is a loyalty member
a loyalty member is someone who has a
loyalty account with us
loyalty accounts let users accumulate
rewards points which can be redeemed for
in-store Rewards
is there anything else I can help you
with
I am a loyalty member
please tell me the phone number
associated with your account
404-123-4567
welcome back Jennifer
the store located at 263 Onondaga Avenue
is the closest store to you
would you like to order from this store
so now I'm going to ask a question that
illustrates the generative fallback
what am I supposed to do
you are on the store selection screen
the store displayed is the closest store
to you
you must select a store before food can
be ordered or menu questions can be
asked
once a store is selected the store
cannot be changed later
is there anything else I can help you
with
What other stores are nearby
here are some other stores that are
close to you
the stores located at 5084 Mission
Street 2735 Baker Street and 3640
Fillmore Street are the next closest to
you
hello order from Baker Street
got it
you're ready to order from 2735 Baker
Street
you ordered an iced tea last time
would you like to order it again
so here we've we've personalized based
on the the loyalty member or you can
suggest popular items if if they're a
guest user
what's on your lunch menu
our lunch menu has a cheeseburger
Hamburger fried chicken tenders a
chicken wrap turkey club and french
fries
so so this question and the next few
questions again show the capability of
of the Enterprise search of generative
AI so it'll I'll ask some some
open-ended questions and it will direct
me to to the products that fit what I'm
looking for
is there anything under 600 calories
yes several items are under 600 calories
including the fruit oatmeal chicken wrap
and turkey club
how many calories does the turkey club
have
the turkey club has 500 calories
does it have gluten
yes the turkey club contains gluten
what items are gluten free
the fruit oatmeal is the only item
gluten free
okay I'll take a fruit oatmeal
got it
I've added one fruit oatmeal to your
cart
would you like to add a coffee to your
order
so here we've we've taken the
opportunity to to recommend commonly
paired items
sure I'll take two coffees as well
got it
I've added two copies to your cart
cream and sugar will be available at the
store
what else can I get you what soft drinks
do you have
we only have generic soft drinks
you will receive a cup and decide your
drink in store
okay I'll take a soda
got it
I've added one soft drink to your cart
what else can I get you what's in my
cart
I don't have access to that information
here you go she's just generative AI
what's in my cart
your cart has one fruit oatmeal two
coffees and one soft drink
can I get rid of one of the coffees
which item would you like to remove
one of the coffees
no problem
I've removed one copy from your cart
okay I'm ready to check out
your total is 11.28
would you like pay using your card on
file
yes
okay I have placed your order
you should receive a text message
confirming your order and Order pickup
time
thank you for visiting capgemini's
Corner Shop store in a store
so here the digital person makes it more
approachable and Google's gen app
builder along with ccai makes the
channel reach endless with minimal
infrastructure so now I'll ask Steve to
talk about how to enable this in the
Enterprise
thank you very much I'd like to point
out that was proves it was a real demo
because we even had the glitch in it
um if anything we want to see more of
the demo it's on the booth uh you can
speak to some of the developers behind
it Carl Thomas and Charles who can go
into a lot more detail around what
you've just seen
and I think the piece really to talk
about in terms of the right foundations
is there's a lot of pieces to sort of
say about gen AI where you say It's
Magic it's going to be great it solves
world hunger it's not it's a new
technology and it's a new technology
with some incredibly unique problems
that you'll have to face and one of the
things you've got to think about is what
do I need to do in order to be able to
trust it to do business what do I need
to be able to do so it represents my
brand
so one of the things I need to start
with is what are the ethical principles
for your organization when we say
transparent and explainable AI it's a
great thing but absolutely nobody in
this conference understands how an llm
Works internally and reaches an
individual piece but can I explain why
it did it can I bound what it did can I
ensure that it does what it what I want
it to do within it and then explain how
to repeat that
can I make sure that is robust and safe
that when it fails it fails safely
generative AI gives an entire new set of
problems that I have to deal with it
isn't just pass and fail in testing it's
pass
but maybe not because it's hallucinates
you need to think about things you
haven't thought about before
and that's where you take those
principles you take those pieces and you
think about what does it take to really
build trust in AI
I'm not going to go through every single
thing on this slide because I'd be here
for four and a half hours but I'm going
to pick out three number one is there an
accountable owner if we're talking about
a future world in which 50 of the work
in an organization or more is done by AI
that still means that human beings have
a hundred percent of the accountability
there is no ability for a company to go
oh I didn't mean to order 5 000 of those
the AI did it can you just let me off
there is no piece that says okay it
might have insulted you but it was just
the AI that did it it wasn't really a
customer rep there needs to be an
accountable owner to ensure that the AI
is actually taking responsibility
because the only responsibility an AI
ever takes is the responsibility a
person forces it to take if you fire an
AI the rest of the AIS don't learn about
it
second piece ethical data sourcing with
llms with generative AI do you have the
permission to use the data for the
purpose that you are using it are you
allowed to do it and can you prove that
you are allowed to do it you don't want
a court case where you've got this big
model that you're relying upon or a big
Knowledge Graph that you're relying upon
and not be able to prove that the
information within it that you're making
decisions upon you've actually allowed
to have and that final point of proving
decisions can you prove that you took
the most effort to make sure the
decision was correct
can you prove you're in control of the
decision
there's a lot of other things in there
as well but I'm not going to go into
them today
so then the point is reaching scale as
we talked about the start with the
hackathon we went from having a large
community get 10 000 people engaged then
build a huge number of MVPs and then a
few weeks later be standing on stage
doing a demo of something that was
created in a very short compressed
period of time you can achieve
incredible things very quickly
therefore the question is how do you do
that repeatedly when we talk about llms
some companies a few companies like
Google are going to build their own LMS
companies are going to specialize those
things they're going to exist most
people are going to use Foundation
models what does that mean you need to
have the answer is you need a knowledge
model when you think about that demo
you've just seen all of that isn't in
the llm the Palm model didn't know the
price of things it didn't know what was
in the cart that's an API call that's
information about the organization about
the products that said whether it's
gluten-free and how many calories it had
in it that's the knowledge model
constructing a knowledge model alongside
an llm is how you bring your corporate
content securely into the business
process into the engagement with the llm
understanding how your business actually
works how things relate to each other in
a way that we communicated through llms
that then brings into everybody's
favorite term right now prompt
engineering or prompt Whispering the
fact that how you tune and how you talk
to an llm changes it the model and the
prompt Hub is going to be something you
think about the testing and Trust layer
testing generative AI is not like
testing anything else you need evil
testers I know the matter of Google and
we're here today is don't be evil but
your testers for generative I have to be
evil they have to set out to poison the
model they have to set out to push its
boundaries to ensure it stays within
them those are the guard rails that's
the orchestration layer have you put in
place the things that stop it going off
generator value is fantastic at doing
demos that are positive
but you need to do the demos that are
negative you need to test that you can't
do negative things with it as well so
having those guard rails that control
the boundaries of negative is incredibly
important and then on top we all talk
about voice we all talk about the
generative ux and the voice and the LMS
they are fantastic and magical but that
demo also had a generative ux displaying
just a simple bar of products a simple
set of buttons a simple set of things
which actually was part of the user
experience which is created by
generative AI so generative ux isn't
just about voice it's about the whole
multimodal experience when you're
engaging in non-linear conversations
site
the thing about generative AI I would
say is if it was just about building a
better chat bot
it wouldn't actually be that interesting
the question regenerative AI is why
bother
putting real effort into it
if it is just doing chat Bots and the
answer for that is well there really
isn't any point but the thing about
generative AI is it's a lot bigger than
that it does a lot more than that and
I'm not going to read the things the
little things that you can't read the
text on and don't worry I'm not going to
go into those but in terms of what I'd
say is when people start running on the
chat bot they go right we can do chat
Bots we need this advertise I mean this
entire 360 winner go through and you
probably already thought about it you've
gone we're going to do service tickets a
great one we do customer service we're
going to do automate our customer
service using an avatar and that's a
fantastic thing to look at but I'll take
a 10 BET with everybody in this room
maybe not 10 one dollar bet whatever in
this ring and say that actually what
you'll find is when you go and look at
the data that your humans today
the customer service reps who do a
really good job and fix problems when
they fix a problem they document fixed
problem
customer issue resolved
and the call has ended and everybody is
happy and we move on on our way and we
have no documentation about the positive
outcomes
when we fail to fix something we make a
lot of documentation explaining why I
couldn't fix it what I tried to do to
fix it why it isn't my fault that I
couldn't fix it and therefore don't
blame me that it wasn't fixed so I have
huge amounts of volumes of data that I
could automate not fixing things really
well
which is probably not what you're trying
to do the great thing about Jennifer I
therefore is you can say well how can I
get the information on what actually
fixed it well I can take my core history
I can take my GitHub repository changes
I can take my code and system changes
use that together to create a summary of
the call present it back to the core rep
and go is this how you solve the problem
yep great I've now got information which
is about positive outcomes
by using that information on positive
outcomes I can actually now improve my
automatic assistance then I can start
looking at a full Avatar one of the
things I would absolutely recommend to
everybody when you look at this is make
sure you've got the data on positive
outcomes before you try and automate
negative outcomes incredibly quickly
because one of the things you can
absolutely do with generative AI thanks
to hallucinations and all of those
things is very quickly badly automate
negative outcomes another piece that
everybody talks about is they go code
we're going to improve the life of
developers and I speak as a developer
and it's great it's going to improve it
it's gonna be fantastic
what will happen
when we improve development
is the same thing that happens when
we've improved development throughout
the entire history of development we get
asked to build more complicated things
never in my career has somebody said
Steve that thing you built because
you're really old in 1995. can you
rebuild that tomorrow and we're going to
have the same size team that you had in
1995 building that system and you're
just going to take just as long and
we're going to pay you just as much to
do it the system I was building in 1985
I could probably build in a couple of
hours using a point-and-click GUI these
days
that is not what I get asked to build
today so as we automate code we get
loads of generative code what does that
mean I've got a more complicated system
what does that mean the real problem is
if you've generated a huge amount of
code the answer is testing
you're going to have a much more
complicated system to test so one of the
recommendations we'd make is look at
testing as a starting point to drive and
improve your sdlc generative testing
generative AI is phenomenal at testing
Jennifer I didn't start in November last
year Jennifer and I started about 2014
with a thing called generative
adversarial networks with
I won't go into the whole science of it
but the idea of actually how you
generate content and how adversarial
Network work there's a thing within that
which is a very early piece that was
used which is synthetic data which is
generating data llms now enabled us to
generate test cases so there are two
things that generally is phenomenal at
generating linear code so give it an API
generate some test case phenomenal at
that and number two generating test data
absolutely awesome at generating test
data the more generative developed code
you have the more automated your testing
needs to be because the less your people
will understand the generative code if
80 or 40 of your code base has not been
written by the people in your
organization but they still have to
debug it you better make sure your test
harness is there to make sure you push
and test it and it's right into
production
and in terms of the pieces on the Telco
and Retail these are some ways we think
that Telco and Retail are going to be
impacted by generative AI this isn't
just a small change one of the ones and
this is the new version of this slide
when I first did the version of this for
Telco I'd said that generative AI
software-defined networks the
configuration of networks is something
we could see being moved towards
generative AI within the next 12 to 18
months and then a friend of mine Dave
duggle phoned me up and said you know
Sid 12 to 18 months Steve yeah um I've
got a company and we're doing it now
with some telcos do you want to have a
chat so we had a chat we're talking some
companies around it so Enterprise web
you can have a look generative AI used
for software default networks in Telco
commissioning of networks if you can
commission configuration of Telco
networks there's an awful lot of
configuration and provisioning you do
today that you can move to generative AI
fairly quickly so I'm not going to go
through all those pieces the point is we
don't see this as being a little shift
for the organizations we see this is a
fundamental change in the way business
is going to be done way back when the
history lesson type stuff
I was working with a little company
called Google
on the first thing I don't know if
you've heard of them
um who on a little thing they had called
Google Apps Premier Edition it was the
first SAS product they'd had that they
were launching to cons to the Enterprise
space
we at Camp Gemini were the first people
to sort of work with them on it and we
were looking back then at the start of
SAS and the start of cloud and saying
this is going to really change business
this is going to change the way we work
it's going to change the way we edit
documents it's going to change the way
we do CRM cloud is going to change data
centers and change all of that business
and way back then 2008 people were like
well maybe maybe not and I'd say it
probably took a decade before it became
normal but cloud outplayed data centers
that SAS was absolutely the default for
applications generative AI is going to
move faster and have a bigger impact
than either of those two things and for
a really simple reason
when we talked about the context with
the demo and we talked about the fact
that it understood the conversation
you'd had before it's building up a
digital picture of your organization
you're integrating that digital context
to be able to display that to be able to
enrich that to be able to use that for
decisions
if an organization has a digital twin of
its organization and can actually
understand its current operational
context that organization can already
make better decisions that means I can
put on top of it generative AIS that
look at things like supply chain on
networking and say in the operation side
and actually look at how we can adapt
and reconfigure and respond to that
moving context My Consumer Avatar moves
beyond the stage of just being in terms
of making recommendations of sales to
actually a lifetime engagement with my
customers every single one of my
customers has a lifetime engagement with
a single instance of the Avatar which
remembers them this is something if you
want to scare your Chief marketing
officer is you will have an avatar
and then they'll change their branding
in two years time and your customers
will go you can't kill that Avatar
because they will anthropomorphize that
they will believe they have a personal
relationship so if you phone up and the
voice is different or the face is
different
then that person will get won't go oh
it's okay they've run out of branding
campaign it's they just killed the
Avatar that I've been talking to for the
past two years that's a change in how
businesses can be done and it's a great
way to terrify your CMO by the way
and in terms of what it means from a
generative AI perspective if I've got
that digital context if I'm pulling in
external information from the market I'm
able to pull in something that says this
is what the market conditions are this
is what traffic conditions are this is
what prices is this is a resource
availability I know my context when I
start managing my organization what does
generative AI enable me to do back to
that point on synthetic data instead of
just forecasting the future and saying I
reckon we're going to get I don't know
four percent extra sales this quarter I
can simulate a quarter simulate economic
changes within that quarter simulate
product availability changes within that
quarter simulate marketing campaigns
with that in that quarter and see what
is most likely to impact my sales so I
can war game out my business for the
next quarter rather than simply forecast
it and hey Lads let's go for it
that's a change in the way you do
business so we don't see generative AI
as being simply something that moves the
needle in chat Bots or Knowledge
Management or search it moves the needle
in how you fundamentally manage business
because if you can move to a world where
you have a digital twin of the business
that means engineering of that
Foundation to a level where you have
accuracy on your operational view of
your digital reality you can simulate
Futures and therefore dynamically
out-compete the competition
that's a different way of managing
business this is as different to
business today as cloud is the data
center
so
in terms of how we see this in terms in
the future
that's our view at Camp Gemini in terms
of where we would say to go obviously
come to the booth it's all great have a
chat with Kyle have a chat with Thomas
to ask them more about what they did to
build that Avatar because the thing I
want to say about the Avatar that
Jennifer bravely stood up and did the
demo of in front of a live audience is
it isn't just about the llm when we talk
about the trust
the llm isn't the thing that got the
prices the llm isn't the thing that got
the gluten it's about building a system
which understands your business and is
then able to make the responses in the
way the consumer wants to engage
it's more than just an Ln it's about the
overall architecture so
straight after this pretty much how
Keith and Co are going to be talking
about how it impacts uh generative Ai
and development cycles and all those
pieces tomorrow James my partner in
crime on some work we're working on
together is going to go through how
we're doing on reimagining the modern
consumer experience
but the piece we really want to take at
Camp Gemini is we went on a journey with
65 000 people where we educated 10 000
people well we spent three weeks and
created over 50 MVPs and one of those
MVPs we showed you today only a few
weeks later that is how quickly you can
adopt generative Ai and see how it can
impact your business but the reason you
do it and the reason you think about
trust and control is because this is
going to fundamentally change the value
of data and the value of Technology
within the organization if your business
doesn't realize that shift others will
do and will out compete so the thought
we want to leave you is this very quick
to adopt but you need to know how to get
trust and at some stage in the future 50
of the work in your organization is
going to be done by AIS
and the people at this conference are
the ones who have to make sure that the
business is still in control and that is
not a simple task
[Music]